ils ont l' envie de jouer la coupe
d'europe en 2020 donc ça fait toujours
plaisir de faire partie d'un projet et
de l'amener au bout donc
donc voilà j'ai 30 ans je pense que je
peux apporter beaucoup d'expérience et
[Musique]
justement le fait d'être l'une des
pierres angulaires de ce nouveau projet
de repartir vers les sommets
est ce que c'est ça qui nous a vraiment
motivé dans cette décision et à partir
de quel moment vous avez entamé des
discussions avec le club le fait que que
le club allait rejouer découvrira wii
est une des pierres angulaires justement
ce projet oui mais forcément quand un
club vous dis que je veux l'être
redevenir repères dans les années
proches
forcément oui ça me donne envie je
serais pas parti dans un club qui
n'avait pas cet objectif là et qui n'a
pas les moyens surtout parce que fleury
a carrément les moyens sportifs pour
pour faire les coupes d'europe la coupe
d'europe dans deux ans